und tino kubala der partei- und
fraktionschef der ard hat jetzt als
nächste das wort frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
landsleute
herr bundeskanzler eines hat ihre rede
eigentlich deutlich gezeigt deutschland
ist absolut im ungleichgewicht
mittlerweile ist das überall sichtbar wo
vorher sie ihre vorgänger wird die
bundesregierung lange gebaut haben die
deutsche gesellschaft ist gespalten
gespalten in jene die erst an der
tankstelle sehen dass ihr leben nun mehr
geld kostet und solche die schon lange
kein auto mehr besitzen und zukünftig
auch noch für die freiheit frieren soll
nach allen wahlversprechen der spd um
einen höheren mindestlohn stehen die
bundesbürger nun vor den scherben der
illusion von wohlstand und sicherheit
und das haben abschließend sie zu
verantworten herr bundeskanzler auch ihr
haushalt
auch hier haushalt den wir hier beraten
muss eben erwirtschaftet werden und das
machen alle die tagtäglich mit ihrer
arbeit zur wertschöpfung beitragen
einige von ihnen kennen das vielleicht
noch und wissen was das bedeutet werte
kollegen mehr als zwei jahre haben wir
den bürgern viel abverlangt rechtlich
fragwürdige maßnahmen zur bekämpfung des
corona virus haben existenzen gekostet
und wohlstand gefährdet kleine und
mittelständische unternehmen betrifft
das ebenso wie das handwerk doch es sind
genau diese menschen die für den erhalt
unserer sozialen sicherungssysteme
sorgen von da auch von ihnen herr
bundeskanzler kein wort an diese
menschen und denen ist klar am anfang
einer jeden investition muss es eben ein
kassensturz geben das gehört zur
ordentliche haushaltsplanung dazu die
regierenden müssen den bürgern erklären
können wie viel sie wofür ausgeben und
vor allem weshalb und noch viel
wichtiger muss der symbole
unseres landes passieren und nicht
allein im raumschiff berlin plausibel
erscheinen sie müssen eine vision für
deutschland vorlegen davon war heute
kein wort und die muss sich auch in den
hof eines bundeshaushaltes abbilden sie
aber
sie aber formulieren von digitalisierung
und meinen breitband reden von sozialer
gerechtigkeit und erzeugen genau das
gegenteil nämlich spaltung denn so
wichtig und die digitalisierung von
prozessen sein muss die wohnung während
das eben nicht und die allgemeinbildung
zukünftige generationen wurde bislang
auch nicht allzu positiv davon
beeinflusst deutschland meine damen und
herren fehlen facharbeiter und
handwerker ohne diese können technische
anlagen beispielsweise im bereich der
digitalen infrastruktur nicht aufgebaut
und auch nicht gewartet werden dieser
zustand führt nicht zu digitaler
souveränität sondern zu einseitigen
abhängigkeiten es muss zuallererst eine
tragfähige infrastruktur gesichert
werden in den bereichen verkehr
kommunikation gesundheit bildung usw und
die beispiele sind nur eine auswahl und
zeigen eigentlich gleichzeitig wie viele
baustellen wie eigentlich vor uns
herschieben die unterschiede zwischen
ländlichen gebieten und den
ballungsgebieten nehmen in rasendem
tempo zu es ist eben das beschriebene
ungleichgewicht was sie mit ihrer
politischen arbeit tagtäglich verstärken
und versprochen haben insbesondere die
genossen von der spd im wahlkampf des
letzten jahres sehr viel zentral war die
anhebung des mindestlohns aus heutiger
sicht deckt diese erhöhung nicht einmal
mehr die kosten der inflation
nahrungsmittel kraftstoffe waren nur der
anfang mittlerweile folgen waren
knappheit und ist droht der stillstand
der verarbeitenden industrien aufgrund
von fehlenden rohstoffen und welche
maßnahmen ergreift eigentlich die
bundesregierung der bundesfinanzminister
legte gestern seinen haushaltsentwurf
vor nichts konkretes war enthalten auch
heute in den bundeskanzler nichts
konkretes der präsentation überholt
worden sie werde die bundesregierung sie
betreiben die politik der inflation in
diesem land
und sie verstecken hier das interesse an
deutschland und unseren bürgern nicht
einmal mehr stück für stück lassen sie
ihre masken mittlerweile fallen die idee
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft wurde
zugunsten einer ideologisch rot grün
gefärbten staatspolitik begraben bestes
beispiel dafür ist der besuch des
bundesministers robert habeck in katar
meine damen und herren das muss man sich
einmal vorstellen
weil die bundesregierung helfen möchte
russland wirtschaftlich und ökonomisch
auszuhungern sollen wir auf günstige
erdgaslieferungen durch nord stream 1
und 2 verzichten und der
wirtschaftsminister verhandelt die
lieferung von arabischen gas verstöße
gegen menschenrechte scheint plötzlich
keine rolle mehr zu spielen der geehrte
damen und herren mehr doppelmoral der
bundesregierung gibt es wurde doch kaum
und der bundeskanzler
ihre politik markiert ein zeitalter der
extreme der extrempositionen sich frei
von russischem gas machen zu wollen ist
spiegelbildlich mit dem ziel zu sehen
von ciro coebad beide sind ideologie
getriebene tobt bilder die in
unendlichen ressourcen verschwenden und
ihr ziel wenn überhaupt nur ansatzweise
überhaupt erreichen zu können was also
ist denn ihr ziel herr bundeskanzler das
haben sie auch heute nicht klar zum
ausdruck gebracht wohin möchten sie
eigentlich unser land führen im moment
jedenfalls treiben sie den keim immer
tiefer in unsere gesellschaft den
bürgern wird zum beispiel ein freedom
day versprochen und sie erhalten erneut
ein föderales regelkreis ich stimme
ihnen ja zu dass politik immer in
gewissen ausgleich auch bestrebt sein
sollte allerdings muss dieser ausgleich
auch bei der basis der wähler und
natürlich unserer bürger ankommen sie
aber blockieren die zukunft unseres
landes
meine damen und herren
weiterhin im haushalt des bundeskanzlers
findet sich der geschäftsbereich
ostdeutschland davon grund ihn heute
herr bundeskanzler kein einziges wort
wie sie wissen teilen weite gebiete der
neuen bundesländer das gleiche schicksal
wie zum beispiel gebiet der nordrhein
westfalen oder auch im saarland verpackt
wird es unter dem schlagwort
strukturwandel mein lieblingswort es
meint jedoch die deindustrialisierung
weiter landstriche die probleme damit
sind bekannt werden jedoch gerade jetzt
eben nicht angepackt gelder aus
strukturfonds programm werden in kultur
und prestige objekte investiert anstelle
davon wertschöpfende arbeitsplätze zu
schaffen man sieht es wirklich in
ostdeutschland überall wenn im
tennisheim gebaut radwege aber für
bestehende betriebe ist ihm kein geld da
wir müssen in förderung für
wertschöpfende betriebe und auch
arbeitsplätze schaffen und das hat die
vorhergehende bundesregierung aber auch
diese komplett verpasst
und die debatte um energiesicherheit
nicht vor uns auf dem tisch es handelt
sich dabei um die grundversorgung
unserer bürger und unserer wirtschaft
und herbig wissen sie eigentlich wie
lange es dauert bis man großmaschinen
oder auch kraftwerke in betrieb genommen
hat denn wenn das so wäre und wir es
wüssten würden sie mit der real gefangen
gefahr eines blackouts ganz anders
umgehen auch hier wieder die
ideologische verblendung in einer
politisch und existenziell so wichtigen
debatte sie wissen es alternative
energieträger sind eben nicht
grundlastfähig eine debatte um moderne
gas- und kernkraftwerke ist in diesem
zusammenhang längst überfällig und die
fehlt
den östlichen bundesländern wird der
strukturwandel eines jedenfalls nicht
gewähren wohlstand sicherheit und ein
wirtschaftliches umfeld in denen sich
gerade junge generation
lassen können und die ohnehin verfrühte
abkehr vom letzten fossilen
energieträger in deutschland der
braunkohle bis 2030 muss jetzt eben
revidiert werden ja und das sage ich
ganz bewusst ja es ist wichtig auch über
naturschutz zu reden aber das
wohlergehen der menschen das muss hier
priorität haben und ich wiederhole mich
wir sprechen hier von der
grundversorgung und die muss ein staat
garantieren ebenso eine staatliche
aufgabe ist das thema innere sicherheit
jetzt werden stimmen laut mann soll er
kriegsflüchtlinge auf die bundesländer
im osten verteilen dort leben ja sie
sich weniger menschen es habe ich alles
schon mal gehört 2015 auch hier wird
wieder der zweite vor dem ersten schritt
gemacht zuerst müssen wir erstmal wissen
und darauf kommt es an faeser wer kommt
denn eigentlich in salla diese litt
menschen müssen registriert werden in
keinem anderen land der erde mit 192
staaten kann man einfach ein riesen ohne
registriert und kontrolliert worden sie
seien in deutschland ist das möglich und
können sie so die frage muss gewertet
wie können sie so überhaupt die
sicherheit der kriegsflüchtlinge und
auch der anderen bürger in deutschland
garantieren diese politik herr scholz
ist eben nicht zu ende gedacht und meine
damen und herren wir müssen unter allen
umständen verhindern dass konfliktherde
auf deutschland übergreifen und ja wir
haben krieg in europa aber wir befinden
uns nicht im krieg mit irgend einen
start und das soll auch so bleiben wir
lassen uns auch nicht einen dritten
weltkrieg hinein ziehen nicht durch
worte und auch nicht durch
versprechungen wie beispielsweise
waffenlieferung in das kriegsgebiet der
ukraine werte bundesregierung eskalieren
sie nicht ständig höher weder 500
millionen euro noch 1 milliarden euro
für waffen werden den krieg in der
ukraine beenden vielmehr wird durch
diese fehlgeleitete politik auch noch
blut an den händen der deutschen bürger
kleben das darf nicht sein und eine
sozialdemokratisch geführte
bundesregierung russell zu mindestens
indirekt in europa mit dem säbel und hat
hier seine bilder nach vier monaten kaum
noch mehr als inflation neue schulden
und soziale verarmung im angebot dass
herr bundeskanzler werden unsere kinder
und enkelkinder ihr ganzes leben
abtragen müssen
und lassen sie mich in diesem
zusammenhang kurz auf die
finanzierungspläne der bundeswehr
eingehen wofür wird der
verteidigungsetat eigentlich seit jahren
verwendet diese frage muss man sich ja
jetzt bei dieser debatte stellen hier
würde nämlich nur der mangel verwaltet
den schon die letzten drei
verteidigungsminister identifiziert
hatten und herzig muss in ihrer rede die
ich ag angehört da wirklich sagen was
das wird die zur bundeswehr gesagt
hatten das ist ja schon fast kabarett
sie waren ja gleich 13 jahre nicht da
aber vielleicht sollten sich mal mit
frau von der leyen einen tisch setzen
wofür das geld eigentlich ausgegeben
wurde für beraterverträge wurde das geld
zum fenster rausgeschmissen das hat auch
die cdu mit zu verantworten
und wer die kollegen
die bundeswehr gehört zu deutschland und
wir brauchen eine verteidigungsarmee die
sowohl materiell als auch personell gut
ausgestattet ist allerdings sollte man
sich wirklich fragen weshalb die debatte
gerade jetzt mit so viel energie
betrieben wird denn eines steht auch
fest auch die unreflektierte summe von
100 milliarden euro wird der lage der
bundeswehr innerhalb
kürzester zeit nicht verbessern neue und
moderne waffensysteme brauche
zuallererst 1 menschen menschen die
diese auch bedienen können und wie soll
die neue bundeswehr eigentlich personell
aussehen auch das muss ja mal debattiert
und diskutiert denn bevor man über
weitere kosten und weitere summen
spricht während die neuen generationen
dort ihr vater dann eigentlich
verteidigen können und vor allen dingen
wollen und lassen sie mich dazu was
persönliches sagen ich habe drei kinder
davon zwei söhne und ich frage sie haben
ja auch kinder und enkelkinder würden
sie herrn lauterbach
verteidigungsminister lamprecht frau
berbalk 1 linda einfarbig und ein stolz
ihre kinder anvertrauen dieser
bundesregierung die ja das kann ich
nicht und ich würde das sage ich auch
ganz ehrlich meine kinder auch nicht
kann märz an vertrauen denn mit herrn
merz als bundeskanzler wären wir schon
im dritten weltkrieg und hier geht es
nämlich genau um das über das wir hier
im bundestag auch reden müssen hier geht
es um identität um deutsche tugenden um
ehrlichkeit fleiß und das braucht die
zukünftige generation und vor allen
dingen vaterlandsliebe das muss
gewährleistet sein den mentalitäten
lassen sich zum glück nicht auf
knopfdruck ändern und verstehen sie mich
bitte nicht falsch aber ich würde mich
freuen wenn sich konflikte allein durch
gespräche lösen ließen und ich meine
dass jetzt die zeit der diplomatie erst
begonnen hat und deshalb schicken sie
die tomaten an stadtwachen agieren sie
als vermittler denn nur so schafft man
frieden vielen dank
tv kino kubala war das für die afg hat
nochmal mit recht daran erinnert dass
zum kanzleretat ja auch die bereiche
ostdeutschland kultur und integration
gehören die generaldebatte im deutschen
bundestag wird sicherlich auch genutzt
werden zu einer abrechnung mit der mit
der politik der bundesregierung es hat
ja für durch märz aber schon mit an die
100 tage frist ebelings die idee stammt
vom amerikanischen präsidenten fronten
die
während der weltwirtschaftskrise 1933
hatte die medien gebeten 100 tage
abzuwarten wie sein new die programm
wirke so und die nächste rednerin ist
die fraktionschefin der grünen verdreht
sind liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
habe gestern abend einen artikel gelesen
geschrieben von den letzten zwei
internationalen journalisten die bis vor
kurzem noch aus mario pohl berichtet
haben sie haben geschrieben wir sind
geblieben obwohl es lebensgefährlich war
weil die welt wissen muss was hier
passiert weil die welt wissen muss wie
die wahrheit aussieht und sie haben
recht es ist unser aller aufgabe über
die wahrheit in diesen krieg zu sprechen
auch wenn sie kaum auszuhalten ist auch
wenn die bilder die geschichten die wir
über diesen krieg erfahren so er
unerträglich sind dass man kaum darüber
sprechen kann über die kinder die im
bombenhagel sterben über geburtskliniken
die beschossen werden und so viele tote
dass sie nicht einmal mehr ordentlich
begraben werden können über all das
müssen wir sprechen die welt muss die
wahrheit wissen denn nichts fürchtet
putin mehr
unter druck etwa das mit allen mittel
immer härter immer autoritärer die
informationsmöglichkeiten für sein
eigenes volk deshalb spielt er jeden in
russland weg der es wagt einen anderen
gedanken zu formulieren
und nichts fürchten autorisiere mehr als
die idee von demokratie und freiheit
auch deshalb versucht putin gerade die
ukraine zu zerstören doch an dieser
stelle das sage ich ganz klar hat putin
den krieg schon längst verloren die idee
von demokratie und freiheit ist so stark
die kann man nicht recht konnten die ist
großstadt kann man auch nicht weg
stellen das beweisen die vielen mutigen
menschen in seinem land jeden tag und es
ist unser aller aufgabe hier in europa
die es zu verteidigen und zu den wenigen
positiven erfahrungen in dieser dunklen
in dieser grausamkeit gehört ist dass
die eu und das die demokratischen länder
in europa ist geschafft haben viel
gemeinsam zu stehen es ist gut zu sehen
mit welcher geschlossenheit mit welcher
entschlossenheit die europäischen
staaten direkt nachkriegs gewinnt
gemeinsam mit ihren verbündeten ein
hartes ein scharfes wirtschafts
sanktionspaket auf den weg gebracht
haben in einem ausmaß dass wir noch
niemals geschlossen haben
mit aktionen wie gesagt die übung der
russischen zentralbank über diese
vorräte noch nicht einmal diskutiert
hatten diese sanktionen werden die
russische wirtschaft hart treffen sie
leidet jetzt schon stark darunter aber
es ist natürlich auch wichtig dass wir
weiter an zusätzlichen sanktionen
arbeiten jeden tag auch mit blick auf
die fossilen importe aus russland
und ich bin extrem froh dass die
europäische union ist in dieser krise
geschafft hat zusammenzustehen in einer
frage in der sie in der vergangenheit
immer gescheitert ist das ist geschafft
hat jetzt solidarisch zusammen zu stehen
bei der aufnahme der vielen geflüchteten
die aus der ukraine zu uns kommen dass
wir einmal unserem gesagt haben wir
helfen schnell und unbürokratisch wir
kriegen das gemeinsam hin
und das funktioniert das liegt auch an
den großartigen hilfsbereitschaft der
menschen überall in europa menschen die
einfach zu hauptbahnhöfen gehen und den
erschöpften familien die dort ankommen
einen platz in ihrer eigenen wohnung
anbieten
ehrenamtlichen zivilgesellschaft
feuerwehr thw die schon während corona
so viel geleistet haben und die auch
jetzt wieder da sind ganz
selbstverständlich und helfen und
infrastruktur und unterstützung aufbauen
ihnen allen gehört unser dank
es ist unser job diese hilfe jetzt
besser zu koordinieren ist es unser job
die kommunen hierbei zu unterstützen und
es ist auch unser job die länder
innerhalb europas zu unterstützen die
hierbei jetzt an ihre grenzen stoßen und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass annalena
baerbock dass unsere aus ministerin
gerade noch mal betont hat dass es eine
luftbrücke braucht innerhalb der
europäischen union um zu einer
gemeinsamen solidarischen unterbringung
und verteilung der geflüchteten menschen
zu kommen
und liebe kollegen
das was putin gerade macht das
erschüttert ganz europa es ist ein
angriffskrieg der unser aller sicherheit
infrage stellt uns in so einer krassen
situation da muss politik in der lage
sein entscheidungen neu zu bewerten und
dazu gehört für uns auch die
entscheidung über investitionen in
unsere eigene und in die europäische
sicherheit in dieser gefährlichen zeit
in der die sicherheit in europa so
herausgefordert ist ist es sinnvoll auch
als deutsche bundesregierung die
aufgaben in unsere eigene sicherheit
deutlich zu erhöhen und deshalb ist es
richtig ein sondervermögen zu schaffen
außerhalb der schuldenbremse dass diese
investition ermöglicht
märz ich habe über regel werden zugehört
und sie hat mich in teilen auch
erschüttert es hat mich erschüttert dass
sie es geschafft haben so lange an
diesem weg nach vorn zu stehen und
keinen einzigen satz über die situation
der menschen in der ukraine zu verlieren
das wäre die verantwortung gewesen ich
finde es jedoch nicht getan hat
und auch bei dem worüber wir gesprochen
haben habe ich mich gefragt warum das so
verwirrt dass sie ausgerechnet der fdp
vorwerfen dass in 16 jahren in denen die
cdu das vertrauen und die csu das
verteidigungsministerium verantwortet
haben dass sie es gar nicht geschafft
haben die bundeswehr mit ausreichende
ausrüstung zu unterstützen in einer zeit
in der wolfgang schäuble finanzminister
war es der fdp vorzuwerfen dass sie es
nicht gebacken gekriegt haben das fand
ich eigentlich
und ich sage ihnen auch klar wir müssen
und mehr investieren in die sicherheit
und wir müssen mehr investieren in die
ausrüstung der bundeswehr
es waren dieser beschaffungsplan die
dazu geführt haben dass die jetzt so
schlecht aufgestellt ist aber wir müssen
sicherheit eben auch breiter definieren
sicherheit im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert bedeutet eben auch gerüstet
zu sein und gegen cyberangriffe das ist
moderne sicherheitspolitik und
sicherheit eben auch unsere
partnerländer hat sich als unterstützen
wir leben in einer global vernetzten
welt da kann man sicherheit nicht mehr
national denken und ich kann es mir
eigentlich nur also ein bisschen
störrisch erklären dass sie das was wir
gemeinsam im rahmen der nato als
sicherheitsbegriff verankert haben
vereinbart haben und worauf sie in der
haushaltsplanung in den sechs letzten 16
jahren gestürzt haben dass sie jetzt das
hier in frage stellen wollen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
es gesagt in einer zeit die so krass ist
wie diese muss man in der lage sein
fragen neu zu bewerten und zu neuen
schlüssel zu kommen und deswegen erwerbs
habe ich mich auch gewundert dass wir
die beide keinen einzigen satz zum thema
energie souveränität gehört haben wir
sind in vollem maße abhängig von
russischem gas kommt kohle und öl und es
ist die politik der union in den letzten
16 jahren gewesen die uns in diese
fatale abhängigkeit geführt haben
die situation nicht sein müssen wenn die
ernte märkten mit dem ausbau der neue
dann energien und energie sind was wir
in den letzten jahren von ihnen immer
wieder gehört haben zuallererst bei dem
projekt nord stream 2 war projekte mit
russland das ist nur wirtschaft und ich
sage ihnen davon müssen sie sich einmal
und schlussendlich verabschieden man
kann keine geschäfte mit autoritären und
totalitären 7 machen oder das ist eine
außenpolitische bedeutung hat man kann
sich nicht der hat nämlich messen von
fossilien import um ohne das ist ein
extrem hohes sicherheitsrisiko hat und
ja ich weiß warum sie jetzt die
schreiben ich gebe ihnen darauf eine
ganz klare antwort in dieser situation
in der wir so abhängig sind von fossilen
aus russland in der situation in der
putin kinder bombardiert müssen wir
alles dafür tun um unabhängig zu werden
von russischen gas und weil auf den
weltmärkten gerade nichts anderes zu
kaufen ist muss man es auch in katar und
saudi arabien kaufen aber das heißt eben
auch hermann ernst meint mit dieser
politik dann muss man jetzt den weg
gehen und unabhängig werden von fossilen
dann kann man nicht wissen weil sie die
ganze zeit erzählen der für den vollzug
des
atomausstiegs zurückgeben müssen in
mailand und in nordrhein westfalen die
ausbau der windenergie zu blockieren
darf ist alles eine politik die den
ernst der lage die die zeichen der zeit
nicht verstanden hat
sie haben entweder rede kein einziges
wort um sie energieeffizient sie sagt
sie habe in dieser rede keine
perspektive aufgezeigt ich frage nicht
ganz ehrlich warum hat die union mehr
angst vor wärmepumpen der energetischen
gebäudesanierung und von windrädern als
von der abhängigkeit von autoritären
regimen diese antwort müssen sie geben
in starken 1 diese regierung wird einen
aufbruch schaffen wir werden dafür
sorgen dass wir ernst machen mit dem
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien dass
wir auf jedem dach in diesem land
irgendwann eine solarzelle haben dass
wir ernst machen mit der reduzierung von
der abhängigkeit von gas und ich würde
mich freuen wenn die cdu sie nicht die
ganze zeit auf der bremse stehen würde
und
sie haben ja auch schon mit runter
tragen zum haushalt gestellt die haben
gesagt warum reagieren wir
sozialpolitisch nicht auf die lage
derzeit vielleicht ist ihnen den gang
dass der finanzminister schon jetzt
einen ergänzungs haushalt angekündigt
hat weil es notwendig ist die menschen
zu entlasten und einen tag vor eintritt
russland in den krieg haben wir ein
paket in höhe von 13 milliarden euro auf
den weg gebracht mit einer breiten
entlastung von der abschaffung unter der
finanzierung der eeg umlage aus dem
bundeshaushalt über die anhebung des
grundfreibetrags bei der einkommensteuer
über die anhebung des betrags bei der
grundsicherung in form eines einmal
zuschlages kinderzuschlag all das haben
wir jetzt schon auf den weg gebracht um
die menschen in diesem land unterstützen
aber
es ist richtig und das sagen wir ganz
klar die menschen brauchen weitere
entlastung der schon jetzt steigen die
gaspreise enorm schon jetzt ist damit zu
rechnen dass eine durchschnittliche
familie in diesem jahr mehrkosten bei
den gaspreisen von 1000 euro und mehr
haben wird das ist eine belastung bis in
die breite der gesellschaft der rhein
darauf wird diese koalition antworten
geben im rahmen eines ergänzung des
haushaltes breit sozial gerecht und
ökologisch nachhaltig und ich würde mich
freuen wenn die opposition diese letzten
zwei schwachstellen irgendwann beenden
wird und in wie ich mit uns auch geben
würde
die lüge eine der beiden
fraktionsvorsitzenden der bündnisgrünen
sagte die vom demokratie und freiheit
die so stark in die kammern um nicht im
bett bomben und dann hat sie bekannt
dass man mehr investieren müsse in
sicherheit und in die bundeswehr aber
sicherheit und 21 jahrhundert bedeutet
nicht ganz alleine sondern auch zb
maßnahmen die cyber-sicherheit
und ihnen cyber-angriffe dann hat sie
anschluss mehrfach die union scharf
angegriffen sie habe die abhängigkeit
der russischen energie jahrzehntelang
gefördert und nun dietmar bartsch
bester position der linksfraktion
meine damen und herren es ist still
geworden
nicht in der ukraine
dort tobt seit 28 tagen der
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg
wladimir putins gegen die
zivilbevölkerung gegen frauen und kinder
dieser angriff hat einen präsidenten zu
einem kriegsverbrecher gemacht aber
städte geworden meine damen und herren
es ist auch um die ampel sie haben
geschwiegen nach der ansprache des
ukrainischen präsidenten hier im
parlament das war der regierung
im deutschen bundestag unwürdig still
ist es auch geworden
als wirtschaftsminister habe in katar
über menschenrechte geredet hat ganz
demütig hat er dort eine langfristige
energie partnerschaft erbeten und das
ist das land katar wo die
außenministerin damals allerdings noch
nicht außenministerin die fußball-wm
wegnehmen wollte weil die taliban im
emirat ihrer heimat gefunden haben und
weil die arbeiter auf den wm baustellen
mit füßen getreten werden wie der ball
auf dem rasen mit den macht man keine
geschäfte katharina dröge was für eine
doppelmoral das ist werte die leichte
außenpolitik für eine auto prag muss
runter vom platz und der andere kommt
drauf machen wir uns endlich unabhängig
von dieser unerträglichen
energieabhängigkeit das ist doch der weg
massive investitionen in wasserstoff
energetische gebäudesanierung in
erneuerbare energien in die
energieeffizient aber da lässt vier
haushalten zu wünschen übrig das ist
alles viel zu wenig meine damen und
herren sehr groß waren die ankündigung
der ampel im letzten jahr der
möglichkeitsraum habe sich erweitert hat
christian hinter gemacht großes können
geleistet werden und robert habeck
gesagt sie klagen ziemlich großspurig
wie die fußballmannschaft in der
saisonvorbereitung aber mit dem angriff
und mit dem ersten pflichtspiel mit dem
druck der realität geht nicht viel mehr
sie spielen fehlpässe sie streiten
intern kriegen kaum einen erfolgreichen
abschluss hin ich weiß auch ist eine
besondere situation wir haben kriegt
diesen furchtbaren wir haben die
pandemie die herausforderungen des
klimawandels die schreiende soziale
ungerechtigkeit aber auf die tief
liegenden probleme unseres landes die
sozialen verwerfungen und
gesellschaftlichen entfremdung da haben
sie keine antworten die krisen dieser
wochen überfordern sie meine damen und
herren in der ukraine bringen sie den
präsidenten gegen sich auf bei der
pandemie bringen sie die bundesländer
gegen sich auch und bei den steigenden
preisen besondere bei lebensmittel und
energie bringen sie die bürgerinnen und
bürger gegen sich auf weil sie streiten
anstatt zu handeln diese 100 tage ampel
sind ein maß an richtung bisher sie
hatten doch alle drei im wahlkampf
versprochenen entlastung bei den kleinen
und mittleren unternehmen jetzt feiern
sie ihre entlastung aber sie sind keine
entlastungs koalition sie sind eine
belastungs koalition selten haben die
bürger unter einen neuen und einer neuen
regierung in so kurzer zeit so viel
kaufkraft verloren das ist doch die
wahrheit die kaufkraft zielt doch und
nicht einzelne entlastung wasser das ist
die wahrheit die inflation ist so hoch
wie seit jahrzehnten nicht die preise
für lebensmittel energie für sprit die
gehen durch die decke meine damen und
herren und nicht wenige bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes sehen sich zu der
entscheidung gezwungen heizen heizen
oder einkaufen ist dass der respekt von
dem sie immer gesprochen haben nein
meine damen und herren das ist
respektlos diese preis explosion die
produziert millionen verlierer familien
kinder rentner und ein gewinner was
finanzminister christian linder für
dieses jahr gibt es allein 20 milliarden
mehreinnahmen über die höheren preise
über die mehrwertsteuer aber das ist das
geld der bürgerinnen und bürger folgen
sie doch endlich unseren europäischen
nachbarn und entlasten sie die
bürgerinnen und bürger bei lebensmittel
und bei energie zehn länder haben da was
auf den weg gebracht unterschiedliche
initiativen und sie kündigen ankündigen
an und machen mini maßnahmen das reicht
nicht die ampel diskutiert widerspricht
sich aber die unternehmen und die
bürgerinnen und bürger brauchen jetzt
entlastung und nicht erst mit der
steuererklärung
und die mineralien und raffinerien die
sich rechtlich dagegen die haben
natürlich kein problem wenn ihnen die
bundesregierung die gewinne sicher aber
an die an die trauen sie sich nicht ran
die profite der konzerne steigen und der
zahl der staat zahlt das ist doch absurd
meine damen und herren besteuern sie die
konzerne und senken sie die preise durch
steuerliche zurück reden hilft nicht
handeln ist angesagt und da machen sie
deutlich zu wenig wollen sie wirklich so
lange warten bis die preise wieder
sinken die spritpreise verschaukeln
können sich die bürgerinnen und bürger
wirklich allein meine damen und herren
die mehrheit der arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer der rentnerinnen und
rentner verliert in diesen wochen in
rekordzeit an wohlstand und das ist und
bleibt inakzeptabel wenn sie mir sagen
was wäre gewesen endlich finanzierbar
die bürgerinnen und bürger schützen sie
nicht vor der preis explosion aber über
nacht erklären sie 100 milliarden ein
sondervermögen für aufrüstung der
bundeswehr das ist da warum eigentlich
100 milliarden und nicht vielleicht 87
oder 112 geht es ihnen um den bedarf
oder geht es für ihn um eine
schlagzeilenträchtige zahl ich habe das
gefühl zweiteres meine damen und herren
was sie da vorhaben ist der wahnsinn und
im gegensatz zu den anderen fraktionen
dieses hauses kann ich eines sagen wir
streiten nicht darum wer der beste bei
aufrüstung ist wir finden den weg falsch
wir wollen einen anderen weg gehen und
da werden sie von der linken immer
wieder stand haben auch bei der
grundgesetzänderung meine damen und
herren und will mal ergänzen sagen und
aus ihren koalitionsvertrag zitiert
sie schreiben darin die ausgaben für
krisen präsentation klebt diesen
prävention humanitäre hilfe und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
sollen im maßstab eins zu eins wie die
ausgaben für verteidigung steigen auf
der grundlage des haushalts 20 21 aber
der etat wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
und entwicklung den kürzen sie sogar ihr
haushalt verstößt gegen den eigenen
koalitionsvertrag
oder gibt es ein sondervermögen
humanitäre hilfe nichts davon habe ich
gehört meine damen und herren und auch
hier auch wir als linke sagen natürlich
muss die bundeswehr ordentlich
ausgestattet werden aber wer die
strukturen bei der bundeswehr nicht
grundlegend reformiert und das
management problem ab stellt der wirt
weiter milliarden verbrennen zu spät
teurer als geplant nicht einsatzfähig so
läuft doch die beschaffung der
bundeswehr bisher seit jahren und ich
weiß auch noch wer die
verteidigungsministerin und die
verteidigungsminister gestellt hat die
bundeswehr hat nicht zuerst ein geld
sondern ein strukturproblem meine damen
und herren und wenn sie das nicht lösen
werden weiter mit lagen einfach versenkt
werden
und wir haben in unserer gesellschaft
geben auch das gegenstück jedes fünfte
kind in deutschland wächst in armut da
viel geld für bücher für eine jacke im
frühling für einen ausflug in den zoo
mehr als 20% armut unter kindern 20 euro
mehr gibt es jetzt für 2,9 millionen
kindern haben der reale mehrbedarf laut
sozialverbänden liegt aber bei 78 euro
das geld ist komischerweise nicht da es
ist deshalb eine politik der sozialen
kälte dass sie die kindergrundsicherung
die sie am koalitionsvertrag und was wir
gelobt haben aufgeschrieben haben bisher
0 im haushalt berücksichtigt 0 ist im
haushalt eingestellt die kinder bleiben
haben das ein armutszeugnis für ihre
politik sie gründe arbeitsproben
donnerwetter haben sich die
kindergrundsicherung vielleicht schon
abgeschrieben
ihr haus hat meine damen und herren ist
ein sozialpolitisches streichorchester
kindergrundsicherung kommt nicht vor
zusätzliche monate elterngeld wie sie
angekündigt haben wo ist das bürgergeld
statt hartz 4 und was ist eigentlich mit
der rente lieber hubertus heil begrüßte
auch die steigerung das ist überhaupt
gar keine frage aber wir wissen beide
dass das durch die inflation mehr oder
weniger aufgefressen ist im vergleich zu
2003 meine damen und herren hat sich die
zahl der rentnerinnen und rentner die
von grundsicherung also von hartz iv
leben müssen mehr als verdoppelt und
mehr als die hälfte der betroffenen sind
frauen jede dritte rentnerin und jeder
dritte rentner mit 40 jahre
versicherungsjahren muss von einer rente
ab 1200 euro leben bei mir in
mecklenburg vorpommern im übrigen jeder
zweite ein komplettes arbeitsleben und
dann arbeitslos armutsrisiko das ist und
bleibt inakzeptabel das stimmt nie
wieder heil deswegen vorne mit zwei
dinge sie haben vor drei jahren vor drei
jahren einen guten ersten vorschlag
zugrunde vorgelegt er war wirklich gut
im hätten sehr glatt zugestimmt
herausgekommen ist aber unsere förmchen
sie haben das damit begründet dass die
union in der regierung ist okay aber ich
jetzt ist die union nicht mehr in der
regierung sie ist nicht mehr eine
regierung handeln sie jetzt stellen sie
jetzt diese grundrente noch mal hier im
bundestag vor damit wirklich etwas
passiert und zweitens heben sie das
rentenniveau auf 53 prozent an meine
damen und herren
wo sind die europäische abstiegskeller
das ist die wahrheit die renten sind
nicht stabil wenn die beide explodieren
unstrittig meine damen und herren in
diesen zeiten müssen doch stärkere
schultern mehr tragen aber die einzigen
vor die sie sich verlässlich schmeißen
sind die multi millionäre und
milliardäre meine damen und herren in
der pandemie sind die superreichen in
einen einzigen goldrausch verfallen die
zehn reichsten deutschen haben ihr
vermögen um 100 milliarden vergrößert
kein geld da was für eine farce und da
rächt sich dass sich zu beginn ihrer
regierung mit einer großen steuerreform
eine absage erteilt haben was ist denn
mit den steuerversprechen
vermögenssteuer oder vermögensabgabe der
einzige der sein versprechen einlöst
finanzminister linda er ist der
vermögensverwalter der superreichen
meine damen und herren das ist die
wahrheit wer bezahlt denn die 100
milliarden aufrüstung
sozialdemokraten wollten im wahlkampf da
noch bei den starken schultern bei den
dicken portemonnaies zu greifen und was
ist jetzt pustekuchen länder entscheidet
nicht der kanzler wer bezahlt denn den
schuldenhaushalt 20 22 die kleinen leute
bezahlen ihre rechnungen wenn sie die
steuern für die reichen nicht angeben
meine damen und herren die schulden der
bundeswehr sind die streichungen bei
sozialer sicherheit wenn sie nicht den
mut haben endlich bei den vermögenden
etwas abzugreifen und ich sage ihnen
voraus
ich sage ihnen voraus ihre aufrüsten
werden rentnerinnen und rentner
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
hartz4 empfänger mit dem berühmt
berüchtigten gürtel bezahlen den sie
noch enger schnallen sollen meine damen
und herren der haushalt ist wenig
zukunft und kaum zusammenhalt die
haushalt ist ein segen für die
rüstungsindustrie und eine fette
rechnung für die die tagtäglich hart
dafür arbeiten müssen dass sie ihr geld
bekommen das sie planlos teilweise gegen
ihren eigenen koalitionsvertrag
ausgeben herzlichen dank
dibaba
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
hat am anfang seiner rede gesagt dass
stillschweigen der ampel bei
unseren deutschen minister geworden hat
er habe zusammen darauf verwiesen dass
das hunderte milliarden sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr grundfalsch ist und
niemals
zustimmung der linken dafür zu erwarten
sein wird und dann hat er noch gesagt
dass der haushalt eine streich haushalt
ist wahrnehmen ein sozialer
streich haushalt werde sich ausgeloggt
smd jetzt der fdp
fraktionschef
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
überschattet die tagespolitik in einer
weise wie man sie sich nicht hätte
vorstellen können nicht vorstellen
wollen meine damen und herren die
menschen in der ukraine kämpfen ihre
freiheit und viele verlieren dabei
erleben der freiheitskampf der ukraine
er steht für die werte europas für die
werte deutschlands und für unsere
freiheit es ist la die mir putin der
fundamentale werte in frage stellt und
das auch schon über einen sehr langen
zeitraum getan hat meine damen und
herren wir müssen uns daher auch die
frage stellen wie es dazu kommen konnte
und wie wir in europa widerstandsfähiger
gegen freiheit und demokratie feinde
werden
sowohl innerhalb als auch außerhalb
unserer eigenen gesellschaft geht genau
dass dieser krieg den die russische
seite begonnen hat den lucky me putin
begonnen hat der betrifft uns alle in
europa der betrifft uns alle
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer kämpfen
auch zu unsere freiheit das dürfen wir
meine damen und herren diesen menschen
nie vergessen und
der rest in europa die europäische union
die vereinigten staaten von amerika die
nato der westen steht geschlossen und
hat bereits harte sanktionen verhängt
die finanzreserven der russischen
notenbank wurden eingefroren der rubel
ist um über 40 prozent gefallen und mehr
als 400 westliche firmen haben russland
bereits verlassen und den rücken gekehrt
wir wissen dass wirtschaftliche
sanktionen den krieg nicht von heute auf
morgen beenden werden leider deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir uns für
waffenlieferungen entschieden haben
meine damen und herren wir liefern
waffen in einem konfliktgebiet aufgrund
einer absoluten ausnahmesituation damit
bricht diese regierungskoalition mit
einem tabu vorheriger bundesregierung
diese entscheidung ist uns nicht leicht
gefallen ich halte diese entscheidung
für ausdrücklich richtig meine damen und
herren
und hier geht es auch um die frage
verantwortung zu übernehmen ich höre
immer wieder der bundeskanzler herr merz
sagte vor uns so etwas in einem
nebensatz der bundeskanzler seien nicht
laut genug vor zwei wochen habe ich
gelesen lieber herr kollege merz dass
sie als unions vorsitzender über ein
eingreifen der nato und diesen konflikt
spekuliert haben herr merz das ist nicht
nur fahrlässig das ist verantwortungslos
hätten sie besser geschrieben hätten sie
da besser geschrieben
verantwortungsvolles handeln geht auch
in bezug auf unsere streitkräfte meine
damen und herren das ist in reden gesagt
worden wir stellen als ampelkoalition
ein sondervermögen bereit in höhe von
100 milliarden euro zur ausstattung und
zur verbesserten verteidigungs und
bündnisfähigkeit unseres landes und ich
sage dass an dieser stelle in aller
deutlichkeit weil auch das geht leider
manchmal in der tagespolitik und wir
sind es den soldatinnen und soldaten
schuldig dass wir an dieser stelle
handeln denn die stärke der bundeswehr
sie darf nicht gefährdet sein meine
damen und herren und wir alle
wir alle kennen die zahlen die kollegen
kollegen aus dem verteidigungsausschuss
ich habe das im haushaltsausschuss in
der vergangenen wahlperiode gesehen wir
kennen die zahlen und wissen wo die
probleme liegen wir können keine
weiteren abstriche bei der
einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr zu
lassen es geht um die
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands aber
vor allem um die frauen und männer die
bereit sind hier in deutschland ihr
leben für unsere freiheit zu riskieren
hinter unseren soldatinnen und soldaten
müssen wir jetzt insbesondere stehen in
dieser dramatischen
sicherheitspolitischen situation in
europa liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ja herr merz hat das ja getan da ist
der rückblick auch notwendig dass teile
ich ich teile aber ausdrücklich das was
die frühere bundesverteidigungsminister
in annegret kramp-karrenbauer vor
einigen tagen gesagt hat sie sagte ich
bin so wütend auf uns weil wir
historisch versagt haben herr merz sie
hatte recht die vernachlässigung der
truppe war ein historischer fehler und
diesen historischen fehler wird dieser
regierungskoalition jetzt korrigieren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und
musste
davon schon schmunzeln 2 eine sehr
steile these diese aufgestellt haben man
muss sich das überlegen also die
schlechte finanzierung der bundeswehr in
deutschland lag an der
regierungsbeteiligung der freien
demokraten zwischen 2009 und 2013 als
wir unter an den
bundesgesundheitsminister dem
bundesjustizminister den
bundeswirtschaftsminister
die bundesminister für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit oder den außenminister
gestellt haben natürlich lag es nicht
daran dass die union seit 2006 dem
bundesverteidigungsminister gestellt
haben und in deutschland seit 2005 dem
bundeskanzler lieben kollegen kollegen
herr merz die haben gesagt sie haben den
reden gestern gelauscht ich hätte ihnen
geraten sie hätten die letzten 16 jahre
zu hören sollen was in diesem deutschen
bundestag passiert ist das wäre sinnvoll
gewesen lieber kollege
wir dürfen meine damen und herren uns in
bezug auf die auswirkungen dieses
furchtbaren angriffskrieges in europa
nichts vormachen alle bereiche des
zivilen und wirtschaftlichen lebens sind
auch bei uns von diesen krieg betroffen
wir sehen jeden tag ehrenamtliche
helferinnen und helfer an den bahnhöfen
meine damen und herren wir sehen ukraine
rinnen und ukraine ein bussen und bahnen
in unterkünften oder bei freunden und
familien zu hause meine damen und herren
und auch das will ich an dieser stelle
unterstreichen es ist daher eine ganz
zentrale aufgabe den flüchtenden
menschen zu helfen und natürlich dass
auch bundesweit gemeinsam mit ländern
und kommunen zu koordinieren ich bin
stolz auf die solidarität der menschen
in deutschland auch das muss an dieser
stelle gesagt werden herzlichen dank
dafür dass sie dahinter stehen diesen
menschen zu helfen in dieser schwierigen
situation
in diesen tagen auch in bezug auf die
sanktionen wird sehr viel auch über
unsere stärke gesprochen nach was vier
wochen krieg muss man eines sagen die
geopolitische stärke des westens die
geopolitische stärke deutschlands ist
vor allen dingen auch unsere
wirtschaftliche stärke wir müssen diese
sanktionen aufrecht erhalten und
verschärfen können gegebenenfalls
darüber wird jetzt ja bereits wieder
gesprochen nur dann sind wir in der lage
den menschen in der ukraine auch
wirklich zu helfen wenn wir über den
konflikt in der ukraine sprechen müssen
wir auch natürlich über die folgen hier
in deutschland sprechen meine damen und
herren wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
beschäftigten in deutschland
dass die unternehmen diese krise gut
überstehen dazu gehört auch dass wir
über die sehr hohen energiekosten
sprechen müssen über die heizkosten und
über die einkommenssituation der
menschen in unserem land wir haben uns
deshalb als ampelkoalition bereits vor
einigen wochen politisch auf den weg
gemacht und erste entscheidung hier im
deutschen bundestag in der vergangenen
woche getroffen wir verdoppeln den
heizkostenzuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
und wir unterstützen damit vor allen
dingen menschen mit geringen einkommen
im land das ist eine frage der sozialen
gerechtigkeit das sage ich ganz deutlich
an dieser stelle
wir werden die pendlerpauschale anheben
vor allem menschen die jeden tag auf das
auto angewiesen sind um zur arbeit zu
fahren wir haben einmalzahlung für
bezieher von sozialleistungen auf den
weg gebracht und einen sofort zuschlag
für kinder aus sozial schwachen familien
eingeführt dazu kommen die anhebung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrages in noch nie
dagewesener höhe in einem einzigen
schritt und des grundfreibetrages meine
damen und herren und diese maßnahmen
weil ich die die zwischenrufe aus der
union gerade gehört hat diese maßnahmen
werden wir sogar steuerlich rückwirkend
zum ersten januar diesen jahres
einführen um das auch noch mal zu
unterstreichen die beteiligung kollegen
und dann machen wir das meine damen und
herren
doch darauf kann man auch ein stück weit
stolzen und dann machen wir das was die
union jahrelang nicht geschafft hat was
sie jahrelang in ihren wahlprogrammen
gesteht stadt stehen lassen was sie
jahrelang immer wieder aufgerufen hat
aber am ende nicht wirklich durchgesetzt
hat wir werden die menschen insbesondere
bei den stromkosten entlassen diese
bundesregierung aus sozialdemokraten
grünen und freien demokraten
sie wird die eeg-umlage für alle
menschen für alle unternehmen in
deutschland vollständig und für immer
abschaffen und das bereits zum ersten
juli dieses jahres das ist ein verdienst
dieser seite des hauses über das sie den
letzten jahren nur gesprochen haben
liebe kollegen der union
dass die energiekosten bei vielen
unternehmen bis zu mittlerweile 30
prozent und darüber tragen das ist
leider keine seltenheit mehr deshalb
haben wir uns für die genannten
entlastungsschritte entschieden
gleichzeitig müssen wir strategisch
unabhängiger werden insbesondere vom
russischen erdgas meine damen und herren
und deshalb begrüße ich die anstrengung
auch die aktuellen des
bundeswirtschaftsministers auch andere
erdgasquellen jetzt zu erschließen das
ist richtig und entsprechend ist es auch
wichtig in deutschland etwas zu tun und
dabei denke ich natürlich an die lng
terminals die beispielsweise der
bundeskanzler bei seiner
regierungserklärung bereits erwähnt hat
die standorte in wilhelmshaven in
brunsbüttel und als niedersachse darf
ich sagen natürlich auch in staaten denn
eins ist doch ganz klar
danke kollege klingen bei den einst ist
doch auch ganz klar deutschland wird
auch zukünftig auf energieimporte
angewiesen seien und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt die richtigen infrastruktur
entscheidung treffen meine damen und
herren an dieser stelle muss man eines
sagen diese koalition hat eine doppelte
hypothek geerntet nein nicht erhärtet
der entschuldigung eine doppelte
hypothek geerbt auf der einen seite eine
viel zu starke abhängigkeit russlands
bei energieimporten und auf der anderen
seite und deswegen haben wir bereits
entlastet bei energie auf der anderen
seite historische bereits vor der
ukraine krise historische belastung der
deutsche stromkunden der deutschen
kunden für gast et cetera pp das waren
zwei große hypotheken die wir jetzt
bereinigen wollen meine damen und herren
unsere botschaft lautet wir lassen
unsere unternehmen und die menschen in
deutschland bei der frage der
energieversorgung nicht im regen stehen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
diese die arbeit dieser koalition ist
lang bislang bestimmt insbesondere durch
krisen und durch die folgen daraus doch
wir machen uns natürlich auch gedanken
um die zukunft wie wir fortschritt
organisieren wie wir mehr fortschritt
wagen meine damen und herren nicht nur
die krisenbewältigung ist unsere agenda
sondern wir richten den blick nach vorne
und ich will ein punkt ansprechen der in
den letzten jahren in deutschland zu
kurz gekommen ist und mein persönlicher
eindruck ist es lag nicht an den
koalitionspartner spd in vergangenen
jahren ich glaube es ist jetzt die
aufgabe der deutschen politik
insbesondere vor dem hintergrund der
unsicherheit in der welt diese
bundesregierung wird das
aufstiegsversprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft erneuern meine damen und
herren das ist jetzt eine ganz
entscheidende frage auf wie die
zukunftsfähigkeit unseres landes
wir werden uns um gründerinnen und
gründer kümmern wir werden dafür sorgen
die planungszeiten in deutschland zu
halbieren in deutschland gibt es 83
millionen kluge köpfe die lust haben
durchzustarten die lust haben was mit
ihrem leben zu machen die lust haben
sich zu engagieren
ob ehrenamtlich oder im beruf meine
damen und herren diese art der freier
die ich damit meine das eigene leben zu
gestalten daraus etwas zu machen und ja
auch daraus wirtschaftlichen erfolg
zuerst meine damen und herren dieses
zentrale aufstiegsversprechen der
sozialen marktwirtschaft muss jetzt im
21 jahrhundert endlich erneuert werden
nach so vielen jahren des mehls liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir werden das
wir werden das ja sehr konkret tun wir
werden das tun indem wir beispielsweise
4000 talent schulen gründen meine damen
und herren wir werden das und dass es
mir ein herzensanliegen
gerade als ehemaliger landespolitiker
wir werden das machen indem wir einen
digital pack 2.0 endlich auf den weg
bringen meine damen und herren meine
fraktion hat in der vergangenen periode
der unionsgeführten bundesregierung zu
einer grundgesetzänderung mehrheit
geholfen damit ein digital park endlich
bei den schulen ankommt und über jahre
ist nichts passiert ich erinnere mich
sehr genau an die reden der ehemaligen
bundesbildungsministerin an dieser
stelle die schulter zuckend da stand und
man hatte den eindruck sie ist
abteilungsleiterin land schlecht
geführten baumarkt nach dem motto das
ist nicht meine abteilung nein das ist
unsere abteilung der digital praxis
schulen die chancen fähigkeit die frage
eben auch des sozialen aufstiegs durch
bessere bildung das werden wir jetzt
gewährleisten auch das ist eine frage
der sozialen gerechtigkeit die
bildungsfrage ist eine solche frage in
unserem land und dafür bin ich verdiene
schlag war ausdrücklich dankbar die das
zur chefsache gemacht
als koalition wollen wir in den
kommenden wochen deutlich machen dass
wir trotz der panne me bekämpfen trotz
diesen buchbaren krise es natürlich
zusätzliche mittel bereitstellen für die
wichtigen zukunftsaufgaben einerseits
natürlich bei der transformation auch
unserer volkswirtschaft hin zu mehr
klima- und neutralität wichtig ist eben
und das will ich sagen zum schluss
richtig ist dass wahrscheinlich kaum
eine bundesregierung in der geschichte
der bundesregierung bundesrepublik
deutschland wahrscheinlich gar keine
neue bundesregierung unter solchen
rahmenbedingungen
gestartet ist eine pandemie ein krieg in
europa der zusätzlich zu all dem
schrecklichen leid der menschen in der
ukraine auch noch unsere eigene
sicherheit hier in deutschland bedroht
meine damen und herren und gleichzeitig
die gigantische zukunftsaufgaben bei der
digitalisierung bei der dekarbonisierung
unseres landes und das als letzten punkt
natürlich auch bei der demographischen
frage die aus meiner sicht eine
entscheidende soziale frage in den
kommenden jahren sein wird die wahrheit
ist meine damen und herren deutschland
ist eines der ältesten länder der welt
vater ist 81 jahre alt und sehr gesund
und ich freue mich darüber dass menschen
in deutschland gesund älter werden das
ist ein großer zivilisatorischer
fortschritt und gleichzeitig ist eine
gigantische herausforderung wir sehen
das an den zahlen an den zuschüssen im
bundeshaushalt von christian lindner in
die gesetzliche rentenversicherung meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren die
frage der demographie ist eine frage der
so des sozialen zusammenhalts in
deutschland in den kommenden jahren und
wir werden das nicht allein aus eigener
bevölkerung schaffen meine damen und
herren und deswegen ist ein punkt zum
schluss richtig weil ich vorne auch über
die solidarität und offenheit gegenüber
geflüchteten menschen aus der ukraine
sprach gleichzeitig und davon auch los
wirst in die zukunft gedacht müssen wir
auch eine andere historische aufgabe
herr merz als ampel koalition lösen zu
der die union in den letzten 16 jahren
nicht mehr nicht in der lage war wir
müssen aus deutschland endlich ein
modernes einwanderungsland machen meine
damen und herren wir sind es unseren
wohlstand schuldig weltoffen
was unseren wohlstand in zukunft sicher
und gleichzeitig die regierung vorrangig
und unseren platz auch inmitten dieser
weltoffenen länder sichert liebe
kollegen und kolleginnen
dem bundeskanzler dankbar für die rede
heute morgen und ich bin der
bundesfinanzminister sehr dankbar für
einen soliden haushalt und das als
letzten satz frau präsidentin bei der
frage der schuldenbremse ja man kann
unterschiedlicher meinung in der
haushaltspolitik sein aber bei der frage
der schuldenbremse um darin sich an
verträge zu halten da traurig olaf
scholz und diese ampel koalition um
meilen weit mehr als dieser
oppositionsfraktion ganz herzlichen dank
an die kollegen verlegt
zwischen der
fdp-fraktionsvorsitzende begann seine
ausführungen mit der bemerkung der
freiheitskampf der ukraine stehe für die
werte europas ein eingreifen der nato
sei verantwortungslos hielt der dem
oppositionschef vor
was war das allerdings was die nato im
kosovo damals gemacht hat 1999 als die
bevölkerung wird abgeschlachtet wurde
war das verantwortungslos oder war das
richtig es war eine rot-grüne regierung
und von anfang an zu sagen die nato wird
auf keinen fall eingreifen sowie das
herbei die nato gemacht habe war das
verantwortungsvoll ist ja heute in einem
fast erschöpfenden bei trainer mathias
middelberg cdu ihre eigene regierung
gelobt
unter erwähnung der einzelnen minister
kollegen und kolleginnen und herr dürr
hat eben schon die regierungspolitik
gelobt die noch gar nicht stattgefunden
hat mit allen möglichen ankündigung
dass
beeindruckt vielleicht den einen oder
anderen in ihren eigenen reihen aber
wenn man jetzt mal ganz nüchtern bilanz
zieht über die letzten 100 tage und sich
ein paar projekte sehr konkret anguckt
dann kommt man glaube ich zu einer
nüchterneren einschätzung
der bundeskanzler hat hier angekündigt
eine impfpflicht würde eingeführt ende
februar anfang märz der bundeskanzler
immerhin chef der regierung mit der
leitung der regierungsgeschäfte nach der
verfassung beauftragt also das ist schon
eine wertige aussage gehandelt gehandelt
hat die regierung zu diesem thema nicht
jedenfalls haben wir kein handeln der
regierung dazu festgestellt
infektionsschutzgesetz
da feiern sie sich auch für das was sie
gemacht haben tatsächlich haben sie uns
bei der debatte in der letzten woche zum
infektionsschutzgesetz das maximum an
meinungsdifferenzen ihrer koalition
vorgeführt und haben damit gezeigt diese
regierung ist gar nicht handlungsfähig
sie haben das problem an die länder
delegiert weil sie selbst nicht lösungs
fähig sind thema energiepreise herr dürr
sie haben eben gesagt sie freuen sich
darüber dass jetzt in der koalition
darüber gesprochen wird
gesprochen wird das ist natürlich für
die menschen die jetzt in diesen monaten
bangen ob sie überhaupt noch finanziell
klar kommen ob sie ihre tankrechnung
noch bezahlen können die 23 400 euro
mehr als pendler bezahlen müssen die als
busunternehmer um ihre existenz bangen
oder als gewerbetreibende das ist für
die sicherlich eine wichtige information
dass sie über das thema in der koalition
sprechen
besser wär's wenn sie dieses problem
jetzt entschieden angehen würden wir
haben dazu klare vorschläge unterbreitet
die sind sehr einfach umsetzbar wenn sie
das machen würden können wir das in
dieser woche im bundestag noch
beschließen und der bundesrat kann das
dann zeitnah absegnen und dann sind die
dinge unmittelbar an der anstelle
wirksam
thema
thema zeitenwende das hat friedrich merz
völlig zurecht angesprochen und wir
haben ja hier die verschiedenen
konsequenzen auf den furchtbaren krieg
in der ukraine diskutiert und wir haben
auch über das sondervermögen diskutiert
und da glaube ich ist es schon so wie
friedrich merz dass auch festgestellt
hat
irgendwie glaube ich müssen wir das auch
geistig noch nachvollziehen was jetzt
stattfinden muss und vor allen dingen
sie in diesem teil des hauses müssen
dass geistig wirklich verarbeiten ja ich
sage das ganz deutlich ich kann mich
sehr genau an den letzten
bundestagswahlkampf erinnern und da
wurde häufig auch die
verteidigungspolitik die
verteidigungsausgaben die ausgaben für
die bundeswehr diskutiert und dann wurde
in manchen veranstaltungen gefragt wer
ist denn für die einhaltung des zwei
prozent ziels der nato da habe ich die
hand gehoben bei den veranstaltungen und
auch der kollege der fdp der damals
kandidiert hatte die kollegen die
kandidiert haben aus den anderen
parteien haben jeweils gesagt nee das
kommt nicht in frage das ist ein blödes
ziel das man nicht machen die bundeswehr
ist für uns nachrangig wir haben ja kaum
noch relevante verteidigungs aufträge
sondern verein setzte international und
das jetzt einmal verstanden zu haben was
ist denn jetzt die lehre die quintessenz
aus diesem krieg was ist denn die
botschaft
aus diesem unglaublichen tabubruch dass
wir tatsächlich in dem ein oder anderen
punkt umdenken müssen dieses land europa
ist wieder bedroht und wir müssen uns
auch wieder auf ein szenario der
landesverteidigung einstellen und
deswegen müssen wir in dem bereich
nacharbeiten die fdp hat dabei wenig
nachzuarbeiten
aber dieser teil der regierung hat das
wirklich geistig zu verarbeiten und
darstellen wir hier nicht fest
über die verwendung der 104 jahren reden
und dann erklärt uns der kollege kinder
kindler aus der grünen fraktion gestern
da geht es auch um zivile
krisenprävention
irgendwo in teilen der welt dann kann
ich nur sagen das zeigt ganz deutlich
dass die botschaft nicht verstanden
wurde denn der ukraine krieg zeigt uns
dass die massnahmen zivile
krisenprävention
alle maßnahmen der diplomat hier leider
leider gescheitert sind und deswegen
müssen wir zurück zu einem klaren
szenario der absoluten
verteidigungsbereitschaft und
verteidigungsfähigkeit und deswegen ist
unser punkt er dass wir sagen die 100
milliarden müssen der bundeswehr und
ihrer ausstattung zur verfügung stehen
ich will an dem punkt ich will an dem
punkt doch mal nach halten ich fand das
sehr bemerkenswert was vor drei wochen
der kollege habeck der jetzt leider
gerade nicht mehr unter uns ist
dann nehmen wir der ein oder andere dann
erzählen aber zum thema ja super zum
thema waffenlieferungen gesagt hat ich
fand das sehr bemerkenswert da habe ich
sage das ausdrücklich und anerkennt was
sie zum thema waffenlieferungen in der
debatte vor drei wochen die wir hier an
dem sonntag hatten gesagt haben wie sich
auch selber ich sag das mal ein bisschen
damit gequält haben und ihre eigene
fraktion dazu angesprochen haben die
sich nämlich auch mit dem thema quält
und ich habe da durchaus verständnis für
aber das zeigt ja gerade dass man diese
situation diese zeitenwende von der der
bundeskanzler zu recht gesprochen hat
dass wir die wirklich auch geistig
innerlich verarbeiten und darauf
ernsthaft reagieren und das nicht mit
einem lippenbekenntnis getan ist dass
man sagt so jetzt machen wir mal diese
100 milliarden und dann ist die sache
für uns gegessen und die auch noch neben
der schuldenbremse nein wir müssen das
wirklich verstehen und deswegen ist für
uns auch essenziell die forderung dass
wir wenn das wenn die 100 milliarden
sondervermögen auslaufen dass wir danach
daran festhalten müssen dass die
bundeswehr absolut verteidigungs bereit
bleiben muss das muss auch in zukunft so
gelten und deswegen sagen wir gerade die
zwei prozent müssen eingehalten werden
auch über dieses datum des auslaufens
des sondervermögens hinaus
ich hätte jetzt gerne noch einiges zu
ihrem haushalt gesagt da haben sie glück
dass ihnen das jetzt erspart wird mal
meine redezeit leider für den anderen
punkt und die anderen punkte
aufgebraucht ist
aber die bemerkung herr dürr will ich
mir dann doch noch erlauben sie haben
sich eben bei herrn lindner dafür
bedankt dass er einen soliden haushalt
vorlegen würde ich sage ihnen ganz
ehrlich das was vorliegt kann allenfalls
eine vorläufige überschlägige
betrachtung dessen sein mit dem wir noch
irgendwie rechnen müssen denn
ehrlicherweise diskutieren wir in dieser
woche über vier bundeshaushalte den
kernhaushalt mit 100 milliarden
neuverschuldung das sondervermögen mit
100 milliarden neuverschuldung dann
diskutieren wir über einen ergänzungs
haushalt ukraine wo wir gar nicht wissen
wie viel milliarden dar eingebucht
werden sollen und dann diskutieren wir
ehrlicherweise noch über die 60
milliarden die sie hier meinen so rüber
getragen haben von daher vom alten jahr
und der alten regierung jetzt in ihre
zeit das waren kreditermächtigungen die
hätten verfallen müssen weil wir sie für
corona gar nicht in anspruch genommen
haben wie haben sie mitgenommen um sie
jetzt für ganz andere zwecke nämlich als
klima mit einzel setzten das ist die
ehrliche betrachtung also darf und
solide zu sprechen sage ich mal ist
mindestens mal höchst ambitioniert er
nicht der fall
mathias middelberg der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
fraktion am anfang gesagt diese
regierung sei nicht handlungsfähig im
bereich der impfpflicht zb musste man
die entscheidung ja an das hohe haus
hier delegieren weil es innerhalb der
ampel da keine mehrheit dafür gibt und
die bundeswehr müsse sehr verständlich
verteidigungsfähigkeiten auch in zukunft
das 2 prozent zielt müsse eingehalten
werden für die spd bundestagsfraktion
jetzt rolf mützenich fraktionschef
kolleginnen und kollegen
haushaltspolitische debatten werden in
der regel von themen der wirtschaft
sozialklima und innenpolitik dominiert
doch die ukraine die welt und unsere
bisherigen regeln wurden in den
morgenstunden des 24
februar angegriffen
light flucht seit mehr als vier jahren
also seit mehr als vier wochen verstört
uns die brutalität mit der putin einen
staat ein echter will wir sehen aus der
gar nicht so ferne großen ferne bilder
der unmenschlichkeit die wir in europa
nicht mehr für möglich gehalten haben
und wir sehen bei uns besonders aber in
polen ungarn oder moldawien die
millionen von frauen kindern und älteren
menschen fliehen müssen sie alle werden
einer friedlichen heimat beraubt dennoch
darf der krieg die agenda in der wir der
welt von gestern eine neue zukunft
gegenüber stellen wollen nicht aufheben
im gegenteil gerade jetzt sind wir
gefordert
antworten zu geben wie wir nach dem
zweiten bruch des krieges die
herausforderungen für unser land für
europa und den planeten meistern können
der krieg meine damen und herren
hier kriegt meine damen und herren
natürlich verändert zusammen mit den
anderen ländern unterstützen wir ein
beispielloses sanktionsregime das und
wir müssen sagen auch uns nicht
unbeschadet zurück lassen wird die
folgen werden jahre nachwirken wir haben
der ukraine im einklang mit der charta
der vereinten nationen waffen zur
selbstverteidigung
geliefert und leisten wie kein anderes
land wirtschaftliche und humanitäre
hilfe wo wir können werden wir diese
hilfe auch weiterhin leisten unsere
fraktion meine fraktion wird das
verantwortungsvoll und gewissenhaft
zusammen mit der mehrheit dieses hauses
tun darauf meine damen und herren können
sie sich verlassen
gegen wachsen die kommunen und die
zivilgesellschaft über sich hinaus
engagierte bürgerinnen und bürger nehmen
frauen kinder und familien mit großer
wärme in empfang
organisieren kurzfristig eine bleibe
medizinische hilfe und die teilnahme am
schulunterricht für die kinder in
momenten wie diesen meine damen und
herren wird uns gewahr dass unsere
demokratische und bürgerschaftliche
verfasstheit von unschätzbaren wert ist
für ein friedliches
verträgliches miteinander den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt und für
diese gelebte solidarität möchte ich
mich bei den vielen vielen menschen in
deutschland bedanken vielen dank dafür
auch
meine damen und herren in den
organisationen der staatengemeinschaft
tut sich weg weisen dass die europäische
union hat zu neuer geschlossenheit
gefunden morgen besuch der amerikanische
präsident die europäische union und die
nato das in washington mit joe biden ein
staatsoberhaupt amtiert dass die
zusammenarbeit mit europa wie kein
zweiter verkörpert ist ein glücksfall
was für eine erleichterung gegenüber den
erlebten die kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich finde nicht vergessen dürfen wir
den europarat in straßburg und die
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa in wien beide
institutionen haben ihre eigenen stärken
und müssen eine wichtige rolle in der
nachkriegszeit einnehmen zumal die
anstrengungen durch entsandte aus vielen
parlamenten in der osze und im europarat
ergänzt werden können gemeinschaftliches
handeln liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das zeigt sich in diesen wochen ist ein
wert an sich und genau das brauchen wir
in diesen tagen
ebenso
das wird aus meiner sicht vergessen
schafft das völkerrecht klarheit und
überzeugungskraft wir begrüßen
ausdrücklich dass der chef ankläger am
internationalen strafgerichtshof ein
ermittlungsverfahren zu kriegsverbrechen
völkermord und verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit eröffnet hat nach unserem
verständnis
nach unserem verständnis müssen sich die
ermittlungen aber außerdem auf den
vorwurf des angriffskrieges beziehen das
sind wir den opfern und das sind wir der
ukraine schuldig die möglichkeit
verantwortliche persönlich zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen darf nicht
ungenutzt bleiben darauf bestehen wir
meine damen und herren
nachdem auch der internationale
gerichtshof vergangenen mittwoch
angeordnet hat dass russland die
militärische gewalt in der ukraine
sofort beenden muss kann sich niemand
mehr in moskau hinter fadenscheinigen
juristischen argumenten oder
abwegigen vergleichen versteckten die
richterinnen und richter in den haag am
völkerrechtliche klarheit geschaffen das
ist ein fortschritt im internationalen
recht und genau das ist gut auch für
dieses parlament weil wir stehen hinter
dem internationalen recht und haben es
auf den weg gebracht meine damen und
herren
und selbst in new york ist nicht alles
beim alten geblieben zwar hat sich der
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
erneut als unfähig erwiesen seinem
auftrag zur wahrung des internationalen
friedens nachzukommen russland legte
erwartungsgemäß ein veto ein aber auch
die volksrepublik china
enthielt sich der stimme
solange peking und da sage ich hier ganz
klar aus dem manifesten bruch des
völkerrechts keine konsequenzen für das
eigene handeln zieht bleibt die
volksrepublik china hinter den selbst
geweckten erwartungen zurück wir sagen
klar lösen sie sich aus der schlinge
eines kriegsverbrechens solange das noch
möglich ist stellen sie sich auf die
seite der menschlichkeit und des
friedens
aber auch die länder wie die vereinigten
arabischen emiraten haben das privileg
ihres nicht ständigen sitz im
sicherheitsrat nicht ausgefüllt leider
wollte abu dhabi den überfall auf die
ukraine nicht verurteilen
es war daher richtig dass der
wirtschaftsminister
dieses dank dieses verhalten bei seinem
besuch angesprochen hat dafür möchte ich
mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen bedanken
anders als der sicherheitsrat hat die
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen eine klare entscheidung
getroffen
141 von 193 staaten brauchten die
aggressions russlands nur fünf stimmten
mit nein 35 regierungen enthielten sich
der stimme und zwölf repräsentanten
waren in new york nicht anwesend auf den
ersten blick ist das ein klares votum
doch wir sollten genauer hinschauen
zumal wir europäer die größte zahl der
staaten die die militärische aggression
russlands nicht verurteilt haben
befinden sich auf dem eurasischen
kontinent oder in afrika also
unmittelbar in unserer nähe oder in
nicht ganz weiter ferne und deswegen
würde ich ihnen gerne diese karte die
vielleicht die neue weltordnung
zumindestens im entstehen ist
zumindestens vor augen führen weil wir
sollten uns das vergegenwärtigen was das
bedeutet im verhältnis zur
weltbevölkerung ist dass die hälfte der
menschheit darunter befinden sich viele
autoritär regierte staaten aber auch
demokratien wie indien oder
unvollständige demokratien wie südafrika
oder sri lanka fünf staaten welche sich
der verurteilung russlands auf dieser
karte
nicht anschließen wollten sind außerdem
atomwaffen möchte und ich finde es lohnt
sich in einer solchen debatte den blick
auf vielleicht eine weltordnung zugeht
so zu lenken die im entstehen begriffen
ist weil sie ist nicht schwarz oder weiß
wie uns immer einige einreden wollen und
auf diese im entstehen begriffene
weltordnung wird es keine einfachen
antworten geben schon gar nicht allein
militärische und das sollten hoffentlich
den meisten auch in diesem haus klar
sein dass wir die ausrüstung und das
sage ich gleichzeitig mit dazu dass wir
die ausrüstung der soldatinnen und
soldaten verbessern bleibt dennoch
richtig genauso wie die anschaffung von
neuen geräten
meine fraktion wird dabei gleichzeitig
darauf achten und hinwirken dass der
bundestag bei der verausgabung der
mittel ein entscheidendes wort mitreden
wird ohne parlaments kontrolle meine
damen und herren gibt es keine
demokratische sicherheitspolitik und die
bundeswehr muss eine parlamentsarmee
bleiben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die spd ist nach wie vor der auffassung
dass zur kriegs verhinderung mehr gehört
als immer größer rüstungsausgaben und
schon gar nicht gehört dazu
nachfolgenden generationen
vorzuschreiben wie hoch diese zu sein
haben wie die union ist will denn einige
zudem einen zur bündnisverteidigung
gehöre ein weltweites militärisches
engagement unsere streitkräfte dazu so
sagen wie auch dem das ist nicht unser
verständnis einer klugen außen und
sicherheitspolitik denn wir haben
nämlich noch ja genau das nicht das aha
in ihrer fraktion sondern sie hätten
sich in den letzten jahren 16 jahren
dazu durchringen können nämlich wir
haben noch vieles und anderes zu tun
bevor wir allein koleos investitionen
tätigen und immer wieder neue ziele
formulieren
so wie sie das hier tun sollten wir
zuerst klären was die bundeswehr leisten
kann aber auch leisten soll alle sind
1000 einmal wird ja ich atrio angehalten
knacken sie eine frage oder bemerkung
der kollegin zu hindern ja ich wollte
das nicht sie hat sich schon seit zehn
minuten gemeldet ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
sie auch einfach keine luft fitte
ja sehr geehrter kollege mütze nicht
vielen herzlichen dank dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen mir geht es
darum dass sie ja als chef der stärksten
fraktion im deutschen bundestag würde
ich sie einfach persönlich fragen wollen
wir haben situationen alle kümmern sich
im moment in unserem land dankenswerter
weise um die ankommenden flüchtlinge und
auch meiner region sind beispielsweise
aus der region briefen flüchtlinge
angekommen das sind mütter mit kindern
die große sorge haben um ihre männer die
dort an der grenze zu weißrussland
wahrscheinlich massiv unter druck
geraten könnten denn dort besteht die
gefahr dass weiß und russland eine
unrühmliche rolle einnimmt und deswegen
die konkrete frage als sie was
unternehmen sie als chef der stärksten
fraktion im deutschen bundestag um dort
die zivilisten männer die bürger werden
dort zumindest so weit gehend zu
schützen dass sie groß panzer zur
verfügung haben dass sie hell mit zur
verfügung haben denn nach jetzigem
kenntnisstand stehen sie sozusagen mit
bloßen händen dort und haben eben die
berechtigte sorge dass sie dort in einen
weiteren konflikt in eine weitere
auseinandersetzung mit hineingezogen
werden gibt es schon abmachungen mit
unternehmen die brustpanzer produzieren
sie wissen wie es im moment im aktuellen
weltgeschehen
die diesbezüglich aussieht aber am ende
des tages sind die zivilisten es sind
menschen die in der bürgerwehr sich
organisiert haben was unternehmen sie
konkret um dies den menschen zu helfen
losgelöst von den waffen die ja auch zur
debatte stehen aber das ist ja noch mal
eine andere hausnummer die ticken was
unternehmen sie konkret
[Applaus]
kollegin sie in der 2
denn hier in ihrer zwischen
interventionen in ihrer frage
angesprochen
das eine ist dass viele frauen mit ihren
kindern aber auch ältere menschen nach
deutschland kommen und ich habe eben und
ich hoffe für das ganze haus auch gesagt
vielen dank an die die ein
bürgerschaftliches engagement die eine
bleibe diesen menschen geben und ich
denke das werden sie auch ihnen gesagt
haben dass sie willkommen sind und dass
wir alles dafür tun dass in dieser zeit
in der sie bei uns sind humanität der
erste sozusagen das erste angebot an sie
ist und was darauf weiteres folgt und da
will ich auch an die kolleginnen und
kollegen der cdu csu fraktion erinnern
dass die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
eben auch mit unionsgeführten
bundesländer eben genau diese
willkommenskultur
entschieden hat auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber
gleichzeitig auch gesagt hat wir wollen
gemeinsam mit dem bund mit den ländern
und mit den kommunen uns auf den weg
machen letztlich auch die finanziellen
lasten gemeinsam zu teilen das ist meine
einladung an sie helfen sie uns dabei
dass in dieser arbeitsgruppe gutes auf
den weg gebracht wird und das zweite
um das zweite betrieb wie
waffenlieferungen
in der tat diese bundesregierung
zusammen mit dem parlament hat eine
schwerwiegende entscheidung getroffen
und ich habe es ganz bewusst manchmal
über hört man das doch hier dies auch
vor dem hintergrund
des internationalen rechts gesagt der
charta der vereinten nationen auf der
grundlage der charta der vereinten
nationen dass sich nämlich länder selbst
verteidigen können sind auch wir bereit
gewesen an die eine waffen zu liefern
zur selbstverteidigung und ich finde das
ist nicht nur beachtenswert sondern das
ist ein solidarbeitrag dem der innerhalb
des bündnisses innerhalb der
europäischen union aber auch als
souveränes land gegeben haben und ich
finde das können sie den menschen die
sie angesprochen haben auch durchaus
sagen das ist ein wichtiger schritt und
wir werden weiterhin auch diese hilfe
leisten meine damen und herren aber und
das sage ich auch ganz klar sie können
sich ihrer verantwortung nicht entziehen
indem sie hier an die bundeswehr
bestimmte erwartungen äußern ohne aber
uns dabei zu helfen auch andere fragen
mit zu beantworten ja wir wollen große
investitionen tätigen
aber wir wollen eben auch zuerst klären
was diese bundeswehr leisten kann und
was sie leisten soll alles auf einmal
das habe ich gesagt wird dich gehen
zumal die erfahrungen der beschaffung
kollege merz einschließlich der
sonderwünsche einen realitätstest
unterzogen werden müssen warum wir in
europa jährlich mit 200 milliarden euro
verteidigungsausgaben nicht wehrhafter
sein können erschließt sich mir nicht
auch das ist eine große aufgabe
innerhalb der europäischen union aber
auch das militär ins system und
nicht findet zu einer ernsthaften
debatte im deutschen bundestag
gehört genauso mit dazu wie über die
frage der waffenlieferungen zu sprechen
dass wir als stärkste wirtschaftsmacht
in europa zudem lernen müssen lernen
müssen das ist ein langer weg mit den
größten rüstungsetat in europa
verantwortungsvoll umzugehen ohne
humanitäre hilfe wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und abrüstung zu
vernachlässigen wir wollen die die
bereiche genau so gestärkt wir sehen wie
die investition in die bundeswehr meine
damen und
deswegen sage ich auch ganz klar unsere
überzeugung resultieren nicht aus
weltfremden idealismus oder wir uns
immer vorgeworfen wird aus reiner
naivität sie stützen sich auf erfahrung
einer politik die den kalten krieg
maßgeblich mit überwunden hat darauf
werden wir sozialdemokraten immer stolz
zurückblicken und die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen daraus für unser
konkretes heutiges handeln ziehen beide
sich möglich meine damen und herren
genau diesen weg wird meine fraktionen
auch in den nächsten jahren gehen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
pandemien
klimawandel und der krieg in der ukraine
fordern uns alle heraus der
finanzminister hat recht als
solidargemeinschaft müssen wir
zusammenstehen darin der kollege lindner
stimmen wir überein und wenn wir dann
noch übereinkommen dass in gefährlichen
zeiten starke schultern der
solidargemeinschaft zusätzlichen halt
geben müssen tun wir das lieber kollege
lindner auch sehr gerne diese
unterstützung wären sie haben zum
schluss möchte ich auch den moment
zurück kommen als wir in einer neuen
koalition zusammengefunden haben wir
sind gemeinsam der überzeugung innere
reform die soziale kraft und die
sicherung der freiheit sind die besten
antworten auf autoritäre
herausforderungen im inneren wie im
äußeren
wir attraktiv als demokratische
gemeinschaft und konkurrenzfähig als
moderne sozial und wirtschaftsnationen
kurzum wir müssen politisch
wirtschaftlich und technologisch
vorangehen darin liegt die große stärke
unseres landes und seiner menschen und
die bundesregierung und die sie
tragenden parteien werden alles dafür
tun dass das in den nächsten vier jahren
möglich wird liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deswegen
wollen wir gute arbeit durch eine kluge
ökonomische und ökologische
transformation sicherstellen und neue
arbeit schaffen wir wollen die
erfolgreiche tradition einer
kooperativen sozialpolitik anknüpfen und
zusammen mit arbeitgebern gewerkschaften
und den bundesländern unser
wirtschaftsmodell stärken das ist unser
bild von der zukunft und wir werden es
verwirklichen meine damen und herren
nämlich weil wir ein starkes land sind
und mit verstand gewirtschaftet haben
können wir die herausforderungen
meistern wir brauchen soziale sicherheit
im innern gerade dann wenn die äußere
sicherheit bedroht ist dazu gehört
auch die anhebung des mindestlohns
genauso wie das grundrecht auf wohnen zu
erschwinglichen preisen
die pandemie hat uns zudem gelehrt warum
wir ein gesundheitssystem brauchen dass
solidarität gute beschäftigung und
vorsorge zusammen denkt die hand
versprochen dass wir deutschland
moderner ökologischer und gerechter
machen wollen deshalb unterstützt meine
fraktion den etatentwurf der neuen
bundesregierung und wird gleichzeitig
weitere verbesserungen vorschlagen mit
dem haushalt haben wir die
herausforderungen der zeitenwende
angenommen damit schaffen wir ein
fundament für die zukunft und ich finde
diesen weg wollen und können wir
gemeinsam gehen vielen dank
wolf mit zu nicht wahr dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende der
aber darauf hingewiesen dass es nicht
darum gehe immer nur große
rüstungsausgaben skizzieren sondern ohne
humanitäre hilfe und
abrüstungsbemühungen werde es keinen
frieden und zu kommen eben können